une découverte impressionnante après
cinq ans de fouilles sur le site de la
caserne Beaumont les archéologues ont pu
reconstituer entièrement le plan de
l'abbaye bénédictène qui fonctionnait du
11e au 18e siècle les recherches ont
également permis de mettre au jour un
cimetière de 3000 tombes millénaires
sous les vestiges de l'abbaye des
fouilles d'envergure exceptionnellement
l'implantation prévue sur le site d'un
nouveau quartier et c'est 780 logements
Léa Turquie et Sarah gros
et là le petit sondage qu'on a réalisé
depuis deux semaines a permis de mettre
à jour un sarcophage et plusieurs
coffrages coffrage c'est des assemblages
de pierres qui entourent les corps si
vous approchez vous pouvez voir qu'il y
a encore des restes de squelette à
l'intérieur c'est sépultures viennent
tout juste d'être mis au jour elles sont
le fruit de fouilles archéologique
députés en septembre 2022 sous la pierre
se révèle un cimetière composé de plus
de 3000 tombes datant des 9 et 10ème
siècle une découverte qui permet de
comprendre le lieu sur lequel c'est
érigé l'abbaye pour femme de Beaumont
c'est que ça nous permet de confirmer
que l'abbaye a bien remplacé un
cimetière allez c'est bien implanté sur
un cimetière qui l'a précédé et
également ce qui est vraiment très
intéressant c'est de voir l'évolution de
cette habille ça nous permet de voir
l'évolution des différentes pièces par
exemple on sait que le réfectoire a été
reconstruit les galeries du cloître on
sait qu'elles ont évolué le cloître à
évolué elle s'est agrandi vers le sud et
également vers l'ouest voilà on a on
voit en fait les différentes
constructions sur les huit siècles
d'histoire de l'abbaye
détruit lors de la Révolution française
en 1790 les bâtiments de l'abbaye ont
d'abord été remplacés par des jardins
puis des casernes avant d'être un
écoquartier en 2022 les fouilles sont
réalisés dans un but préventif suite au
projet de réaménagement du site elles
sont là pour conserver le patrimoine
avant sa destruction puisque dans les
constructions à venir il peut y avoir
des sous-sols comme c'est le cas plus à
l'est vous avez des parkings souterrains
qui sont forcément destructifs des
vestiges archéologiques donc en amont de
ces destructions on vient étudier les
vestiges
la préservation du site n’est cependant
pas remise en cause le lieu fera l'objet
d'un nouveau quartier et de passage pour
la seconde ligne de tramway quant au
mobilier trouvé il sera prélevé et
étudié avant d'être stockés dans les
réserves de l'État
ces vestiges seront ouverts au public
lors des Journées Européennes de
l'archéologie du 16 au 18 juin